et ce club consacré à la question de la
fin de vie Emmanuel Macron a reçu hier
les conclusions de la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie qui s'est
dit majoritairement favorable à une aide
active à mourir le chef de l'État n'a
pas promis de reprendre tel ou tel
mesure mais c'est engagé à une loi d'ici
la fin de l'été veut mettre en place un
modèle français de la fin de vie on va
en débattre pendant une demi-heure avec
nos invités Véronique Lefevre desnettes
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes médecin spécialisés en
psychiatrie et en gériatrie docteur en
philosophie pratique et éthique médicale
merci d'être la martial breton bonjour
vous êtes membre de cette convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie vous avez
travaillé pendant 27 jours
l'état vous nous raconterez comment ça
s'est passé est-ce que vous pensez de ce
qu'a dit hier Emmanuel Macron Anne
Vivien bonjour merci d'être là
vice-présidente de l'Association pour le
droit de mourir dans la dignité on va
évidemment revenir sur cette convention
citoyenne et sur ce qu'on a dit hier
Emmanuel Macron d'abord un mot peut-être
martial avec vous pour qu'on comprenne
bien comment vous avez travaillé durant
ces 27 jours alors ça d'abord commencé
par un tirage au sort il faut je pense
quand on parle de cette convention il
faut parler de qui à participer c'est
toute la particularité de ce genre de
dispositif et donc ça a été 180 5 puis
en 84 il y a une seule personne quand
même dans tout le dispositif qui a
décidé de quitter parce qu'elle a trouvé
un emploi donc on est resté quand même
presque tout le monde jusqu'au bout donc
c'est un tirage au sort par numéro de
téléphone moi je vous invite à répondre
au numéro masqué maintenant par numéro
de téléphone le soir comme un démarchage
beaucoup pensé à une arnaque mais
finalement c'est pour participer donc on
nous présente le dispositif on nous
demande un certain nombre de questions
sur des critères sociaux démographiques
de niveau de diplôme de d'âge etc pour
construire ce panel miroir de la société
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'est pas strictement
statistiquement représentatif mais
malgré tout pour notre nombre on est un
miroir on est au même niveau d'échelle
de ces différentes critères et voix
auparavant vous n'aviez jamais travaillé
sur cette question de la fin de vie vous
n'aviez jamais réfléchi à titre
personnel à cette question à titre
personnel je j'y connaissais très peu de
choses et là c'était aussi toute la
diversité c'est à dire que par le vécu
il y avait aussi des personnes qui
venaient du monde médical qui avait été
tiré au sort parce que forcément sur 194
personnes c'est assez logique qu'il y
ait des personnes des accompagnants des
médecins des infirmiers moi type
personnel j'y connaissais pas grand
chose on m'aurait posé les questions
dans un sondage à la limite j'aurais pu
répondre très rapidement mais c'est pas
une réponse construite et argumentée ce
qui est aujourd'hui le rendu évidemment
c'est une bonne chose de confier un tel
sujet un sujet d'une telle importance à
des citoyens finalement qui ne
connaissent pas qui ne le maîtrisaient
pas au début de la convention mais je
moi je trouve qu'en tout cas c'est une
très bonne chose d'avoir permis de
parler du sujet de le en fait supprimer
un peu le tabou qui entoure la fin de
vie et les de la mort en France et que
chacun ait pu s'exprimer alors après on
leur a pas confié la décision
mais ils ont fait un travail que je suis
la première étape voilà je trouve qu'ils
ont fait un travail remarquable et et
il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
consultations autour pour moi
l'essentiel c'est d'avoir dédramatisé le
sujet voilà évidemment parler pour vous
Véronique Lefebvre des noix de c'est une
bonne chose cette convention citoyenne
c'était la bonne méthode bien entendu
c'est une très bonne chose la seule
chose que je regrette c'est la question
est-ce que la loi actuelle permet de
répondre à toutes les situations non
bien entendu puisque c'est du cas par
cas c'est de la calvitie que je pense
qu'aucune loi ne permettra de répondre à
toutes les situations de fin de vie bien
sûr on va juste martial mouton est-ce
que vous ou certains des citoyens qui
étaient avec vous avait un a priori il y
avait un avis sur la question en
commençant cette convention et vous avez
évolué cette vos travaux vous ont permis
de changer d'avis sur le sujet et de
voir le sujet différemment absolument je
pense à une certaine conventionnelle qui
était contre qui le dit qui était contre
et qui est encore plus contre moi
j'étais peut-être sur un peu un sujet
philosophique éthique j'aurais eu
tendance à dire oui comme dans un
sondage mais ça m'a permis en fait
d'arrumenter et de savoir pourquoi
j'aurais pu répondre oui et de savoir
que en fait cette question pour ou
contre la nature va mourir au fond elle
il faut dépasser cette question et si on
répond oui c'est comment c'est sous
quelle forme c'est sous quel critères
c'est quelles conditions d'accès c'est
quel modèle d'accompagnement et surtout
ça c'est la moitié de la question et la
question elle est pas sur la loi
strictement elle est sur le cadre
d'accompagnement c'est-à-dire c'est même
plus large que strictement la loi classé
Leonetti et le cadre d'accompagnement il
est insuffisant et toute l'autre moitié
de la réponse c'est plus de moyens pour
les soins palliatifs une revalorisation
des métiers des meilleures conditions de
travail plus de professionnels et de
formation et tout ça c'est essentiel
pour la question de la Dexter on ne peut
pas répondre à l'aide à mourir sans ces
éléments là se lancer ces éléments là et
justement on va voir quels ont été vos
conclusions est-ce que vous a répondu
hier et Emmanuel Macron puisque Alex le
chef de l'État a reçu les membres de la
Convention citoyenne effectivement le
chef de l'État a reçu les travaux le
rapport de la convention citoyenne sur
la fin de vie ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que la majorité des 184 membres de cette
convention citoyenne à voter pour 65
propositions dans l'objectif est
d'améliorer l'accompagnement de la
sainte vie dans notre pays de combler
les inégalités d'accès à une fin de vie
digne et les membres ont aussi voté à
une forte majorité en faveur de l'aide
active à mourir c'est-à-dire
l'euthanasie et le suicide assisté avec
néanmoins des limites par exemple ce
serait exclu pour les personnes mineures
alors que vont devenir ces propositions
citoyennes et bien elles vont sans doute
pour certaines d'entre elles se
retrouver dans un projet de loi écouter
le président de la République je demande
au gouvernement en lien avec les
parlementaires désignés par le président
du Sénat et la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui avec leur conférence des
présidents auront à faire ce travail
transpartisan de mener une oeuvre de
co-construction
sur la base de cette référence solide
qui est celle de la convention citoyenne
et en lien avec toutes les parties
prenantes
je souhaite que ce travail permet de
bâtir un projet de loi d'ici à la fin de
l'été 2023 voilà un projet de loi d'ici
à la fin de l'été c'est ce qui est
ressort de ce discours du président de
la République ce qui ressort des travaux
de la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie c'est la mauvaise qualité de nos
soins palliatifs il existe actuellement
trois lits de soins palliatifs pour
100000 habitants 21 départements dans
notre pays ne disposent pas d'unités de
soins palliatifs et Emmanuel Macron a
l'intention de remédier à ce manque de
moyens il veut lancer un plan sur 10 ans
d'investissement pour améliorer la
qualité de ses soins palliatifs et
l'action la réponse commence aussi à
court terme écouter le Président il nous
faudra donc avancer dans les prochaines
semaines
pour mieux garantir l'égalité d'accès et
développer la prise en charge des soins
palliatifs
cela signifie adapter les réponses en
fonction des publics et des lieux mieux
intégré à l'hôpital les soins palliatifs
dans le parcours de soins
former les professionnels
fixer un seuil de lit identifié par
territoire et un meilleur maillage par
des équipes mobiles pour suivre le
développement des soins palliatifs à
domicile voilà pour la stratégie
d'Emmanuel Macron sur les soins
palliatifs président de la République
qui a aussi annoncé qu'il allait
réutiliser ce modèle de la convention
citoyenne pour travailler sur d'autres
sujets de société est-ce que vous êtes
satisfaite des de la réponse du chef de
l'État aux conclusions de ces travaux de
la convention citoyenne mais oui tout à
fait tout à fait maintenant je sais pas
comment ça va être mis en oeuvre mais à
la DMD nous demandons à égalité
une forte amélioration des soins
palliatifs et un accès universel nous
estimons comme la convention citoyenne
et comme tous les Français qu'ils sont
absolument indispensables
et qu'ils font un travail remarquable et
que la plupart des fins de vie enfin des
morts ce que la fin de vie c'est encore
autre chose mais
se passe en fait bien et en grande
partie grâce aux soins palliatifs mais
ce que nous voulons nous c'est aussi une
liberté de choix pour ces derniers
instants de la vie
et cette liberté de choix nous la
voulons pour tous les Français sans
distinction de moyens sont distinction
de relation et surtout sans être obligé
de s'exiler pour mourir quand on ne veut
pas
qu'on ne peut pas ou quand on ne veut
pas accepter de ne pas pouvoir avoir une
véritable aide active à mourir en raison
de douleur intolérable donc pour vous
renforcer les soins palliatifs garantir
une vraie égalité territoriale mettre
des moyens ça ne suffit pas non pour
c'est important il faut le faire
évidemment mais ça ne s'est primordial
mais c'est en parallèle il faut aussi
ouvrir cette possibilité
Véronique lefelden va être là-dessus
alors évidemment les soins palliatifs
non les soins palliatifs je suis
entièrement d'accord c'est dans mon
hôpital de je suis la seule psychiatre
pour les milliers de gériatrie nous
n'avons que quatre listes liés de soins
identifiés de soins palliatifs une
équipe mobile c'est
totalement insuffisant c'est inique ce
ne sont pas des conditions dignes de fin
de vie mais je m’emploie à diffuser
cette culture palliative de soins
puisque je suis docteur en éthique et en
philosophie je forme tous les personnels
de mon hôpital et les jeunes médecins
depuis des années à travers la médecine
narrative à aborder cette question vous
êtes jeune les jeunes médecins sont
aussi comme vous et ne se posent pas la
question ils sont dans des procédures
ils sont dans des manières de faire et
leur montrer que on peut avoir des
débats j'ai fait moi c'est des débats de
convention dans ma faculté avec des
étudiants de deuxième année on leur a
expliqué la loi cleanetti on leur
expliquait l'euthanasie et le suicide
assisté on les fait voter on les fait
travailler autour de la question de la
mort c'est ça qu'il faut promouvoir
c'est ce que le président a proposé
est-ce que pour vous renforcer et
améliorer considérablement les moyens en
soins palliatifs est-ce que ce sera
suffisant je pense que ce sera suffisant
puisque la plupart des des situations de
fin de vie qui sont bien pris en charge
comme vous venez de très de le dire il
n'y a plus cette demande d'euthanasie
moi ma crainte en tant que psychiatre
c'est d'ouvrir un droit au suicide
assisté moi je passe ma vie à parler
d'amour au bord du gouffre rattraper des
personnes âgées qui souhaitent mourir un
temps donné et puis le temps où je les
prends en charge ne veulent plus du tout
mourir et je m'occupe aussi des
personnes très âgées polypathologiques
atteint le troubles cognitifs qui va
évaluer leur discernement qui va s'en
occuper il n'y a plus de psychiatre vous
savez bien que l'hôpital public est
complètement indésirable donc il faut ce
maillage certes pour les soins
palliatifs mais la formation des jeunes
internes des soignants et aussi que nos
nos nos concitoyens comprennent les
difficultés et les aporis dans lesquels
nous les médecins et les médecins
psychiatre nous nous trouvons nous ne
pouvons pas dans un même service avoir
une unité de ce point palliatifs et une
unité on va donner la mort c'est quelque
chose qui est complètement
contradictoire vous comprenez les gens
que ce soit je comprends très bien mais
je partage pas complètement
moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité entre les soins
palliatifs et la possibilité de choisir
une aide active à mourir je pense que
c'est complémentaire je pense que les
soins palliatifs effectivement
peuvent
au moins temporairement si ce n'est
définitivement
faire changer
l'optique que certaines personnes
peuvent avoir sur leur fins de vie en la
trouvant intolérable que s'ils sont bien
pris en charge d'une façon remarquable
mais qui est rarement vraiment possible
rarement vraiment possible ils vont plus
avoir vraiment envie de mourir mais que
cette envie elle reviendra et d'autres
plusieurs études l'ont prouvé et d'autre
part toutes ces maladies où l'on a des
souffrances dont on sait qu'elles vont
croître jusqu'à la fin de ses jours et
qu'il n'y a pas de traitement comme
toutes les maladies neurodégénératives
et bien les soins palliatifs ne les
prendront pas en compte jusqu'au bout
c'est impossible et plusieurs études
prouvent que même si au moment d'une
bonne prise en charge on abandonne
l'idée de vouloir mourir elle revient
dans un grand nombre de cas c'est là où
c'est là justement le contrat de
non-abandon de noncharnement
thérapeutique et très important à tisser
qu'est-ce que vous croyez que nous avons
fait pendant la covid nous avons regardé
nos malades d'Alzheimer comme ça les
bras balance étouffaient nous les avons
sédatés nous les avons accompagnés et
accompagné tant que faire ce peu les
familles qui étaient privées de voir les
leurs qui mouraient et ce sont surtout
des personnes âgées très âgés polypes
pathologiques qui décèdent et notre
société n'est pas bienveillante
vis-à-vis de nos aînés donc c'est très
important en compositionne ce regard et
merci à vous de l'avoir fait marcelet
chose en tout cas les conclusions de la
convention ça a été en effet de
constater le manque aujourd'hui de
moyens je rejoins tout à fait sur les
questions psychiatriques sur les
maladies psychiatriques sur les
souffrances psychologiques et de dire
qu'on a beaucoup on sait qu'il y a une
un manque flagrant dans notre pays sur
ces questions là aussi parce qu'on a
tendance à à désestimé par rapport aux
souffrances physiques et à regarder ça
sur un plan différent et de plus en plus
je pense que les questions
psychiatriques psychologiques sont de
plus en plus et c'est bien mis en avant
comme aussi importantes et on a besoin
de beaucoup plus de professionnels en
revanche en effet la question se pose
est-ce que la loi doit considérer
l'ensemble des situations et ça ça a été
un peu c'est la deuxième partie de la
question existe-t-il des situations qui
ne sont pas couvertes aujourd'hui et
nous on est on a estimé que oui il y a
même si c'est quelques % parce que si on
regarde les pays étrangers on a aussi
entendu des pays étrangers qui ont
légiféré de 3 4% en général malgré tout
sur le nombre de décès environ 600 650
000 si je me trompe pas ça représente
quand même quelques milliers voire
dizaines de milliers de personnes
on a estimé à 75% dans la convention que
le cadre d'accompagnement doit
considérer ces situations là doit
considérer les situations la demande de
fin de vie de mourir et d'être
accompagné dans la mort reste et étirer
du cible et sur la sur l'argument de
cette demande qui disparaît moi je pense
que tout le monde soit que personne ne
souhaite être accompagné en en dans un
parcours d'aide activement on ne veut
pas pousser des personnes à avoir
recours à ça en revanche je pense que
c'est un peu hypocrite de dire les
demandes disparaissent parce que quand
on demande une première fois une
deuxième fois une troisième fois et
qu'on nous dit oui mais quel que soit
les situations on ne peut pas le faire
en fait il y a aussi cet argument là
c'est aussi que en fait la demande
disparaît parce que l'accompagnement est
là mais aussi parce qu'on n'a pas le
droit donc en fait on ne va pas demander
50 fois quelque chose auquel le corps
médical nous dit mais on ne peut pas et
il y a aussi des situations déjà de
d'aide à mourir qui se passe dans
l'illégalité qui sont aujourd'hui ou des
médecins parfois sont
enfin réaliser un acte qui est
aujourd'hui considéré comme illégal qui
peut entraîner des conséquences
juridictrographe ça existe aussi déjà
vous parliez du fait que toutes les
personnes ne sont pas couvertes par la
loi qu'il y a des situations qui ne sont
pas couvertes par la loi justement on va
écouter des témoignages de patients et
d'accompagnants recueillis par Adam
créatrice d'entreprise agent d'artiste
sportive Catherine icardie Lazareff
était une femme hyperactive en septembre
2021 elle est saisie de crampes certains
membres ne répondent plus les médecins
lui diagnostiquent la maladie de Charcot
son quotidien se dégrade peu à peu
je ne veux pas me lever pour aller aux
toilettes
bon mamie
pour me transporte c'est
un enfermement dans mon corps petit à
petit alors que j'ai toutes mes facultés
face aux caractères incurable de la
maladie Catherine souhaite avoir accès à
l'euthanasie volontaire il y a un an
elle décide de partir en Belgique pour
entamer des démarches en ce sens une
injustice pour elle je comprends pas
mais
c'est une
une punition
c'est horrible
faire ce chemin on
fonce la loi Claisse Leonetti permet une
sédation profonde pour les personnes en
fin de vie à court terme la maladie de
Charcot n'entre pas dans ce cadre
Sophie grâce à nos elle a pu voir les
effets d'une sédation profonde sa
cousine souffrait d'une maladie
incurable elle l'a assisté dans ses
derniers jours un traumatisme j'ai fait
des cauchemars
j'ai très mal dormi et qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est pas moi qui souffrait
c'était elle quelques années plus tard
elle accompagne son ami Jeannie en
Suisse victime d'un cancer incurable
pour un suicide assister une procédure
très encadrée mais extrêmement onéreuses
entre 10 et 12000 euros qui peut se
payer
10000 euros enfin pour partir en Suisse
tout le monde ne le peut pas
tout le monde ne peut pas physiquement
non plus
prendre une ambulance ou un train pour
aller mourir à l'étranger et les
personnes qui ne le peuvent pas qui ne
le peuvent plus Sophie est par ailleurs
membres de l'ADMD l'Association pour le
droit de mourir dans la dignité allô
bonjour vous êtes à la permanence écoute
de la DMD Claudine fait partie de
l'équipe des écoutants elle et ses
collègues reçoivent entre 12 et 15
appels par jour
30% concerne des procédures à l'étranger
on voulait ça tout organiser on vous
donne une adresse mais ça s'arrêtera là
effectivement oui les gens voudraient
qu'on soit une agence de voyage Claudine
plaide aussi pour une écoute attentive
des patients par le corps médical une
doctrine prônée par l’admd et qui
porterait ses fruits à l'étrange tous
les médecins belges je vous disent la
même chose le fait qu'on dise à une
personne écoutez je vous ai entendu je
comprends votre douleur je comprends
votre souffrance et bien si vous avez
besoin de moi je serai là quand vous me
le demanderez et ben ça c'est un
soulagement actuellement en Europe seul
la Belgique les Pays-Bas et plus
récemment l'Espagne autorise le recours
à l'euthanasie légale et volontaire
comment vous réagissez Véronique
Lefebvre Desnouettes à ce témoignage
notamment de cette personne qui n'est
pas concernée par la loi kless Leonetti
et bien c'est cet accompagnement
qu'il faut pouvoir proposer à toutes les
personnes j'en parle dans mon livre
mourir sur ordonnance est-ce que on
oublie de M de médical dans l'aide
active à mon rire il y a quand même un
médecin qui doit prescrire et lorsqu'on
est psychiatre et bien je vais pas
prescrire du pain total pour que la
personne puisse se suicider ce n'est pas
possible mais lui dire je serai là je
vous ai compris je parle de cinq cas que
j'ai suivi moi de sclérose latérale à
myotrophique ou dès que le diagnostic
est posé il y a des consultations
psychologiques il y a des consultations
psychiatriques moi je les suis en lien
avec mes collègues neurologues déjà de
la maladie de Charcot par exemple c'est
le cas là et bien toute la réponse je
pense que la réponse est cet
accompagnement est de dire je serai là
le moment où vous le souhaitez il y a
d'autres personnes qui sont en train de
la maladie de Charcot et qui se disent
je ne pense pas avoir une vie minuscule
ou une vie indigne d'être vécue je suis
très heureux de vivre aussi avec une
trachéotomie ou pas il faut savoir que
le désir évolue le désir de vivre le
désir de mourir évolue en fonction des
rencontres que l'on fait aussi il faut
être attentif à ce qui se cache derrière
une demande d'euthanasie contre l'autre
témoignage on a médicalisé et sécularisé
la mort personne ne sait plus ce que
c'est qu'une agonie effectivement
l'agonie c'est très compliqué à recevoir
à accompagner les gens moi c'est mon
quotidien et les gens disent à mes
souffrent c'est dans d'atro souffrances
il y a des râles moi j'explique tout ce
processus est important que les gens
s'approprient ça je pense que vous avez
aussi des collègues qui vous ont
expliqué ça et c'est on a trop des
médecins trop de la médecine et ce n'est
pas un catalogue sur lequel on pourra
choisir parce que j'y ai droit c'est une
relation qui se tisse dans une relation
de confiance sur le long terme
oui bon
ce serait c'est très bien pour certaines
personnes pas pour tout le monde et donc
nous ce que nous voulons c'est le choix
c'est ne pas imposer une interdiction là
pour l'instant il y a une interdiction
elle est imposée que toutes les
personnes qui sont très impliquées dans
les soins palliatifs
face un travail remarquable et arrive
effectivement à accompagner jusqu'au
bout un certain nombre de cas mais
certainement pas tous et jamais jamais
ça sera pas possible en aucun cas et
bien nous tout ce que nous voulons
simplement c'est que chacun puisse
s'exprimer et que la volonté et le choix
personnel du malade qui est celui qui
souffre personne d'autre que lui le
soignant ne souffre pas si le soignant
s'ouvre et d'ailleurs les médecins
belges disent que c'est extrêmement
douloureux
pas faire d'une fois par mois non il y a
une souffrance aussi mais c'est pas ça
que je parle c'est pas c'est pas le
soignant ni la famille qui subit la
souffrance physique ou psychique ou on
la partage voilà on la partage de la
partager ça singulière c'est pas vrai
donc mais on essaye de la personne ne
connaît son seuil de tolérance
personnelle avant d'y avoir été
confronté personne et je suis d'accord
avec vous ce seuil change oui en
fonction de l'environnement entre autres
mais pas uniquement nous tous que nous
demandons c'est que la personne
concernée qui est au centre de sa vie et
de sa vie douloureuse éventuellement
soit entendu jusqu'au bout dans sa
demande personnelle voilà mais si cela
est un tout petit non mais elle a des
troupes psychiatriques croyez-vous que
l'on peut choisir lorsqu'on est atteint
le trouble cognitif non mais pour
l'instant lorsqu'on est déprimé
mélancolique mais non mais que la seule
solution que vous entrevoyez c'est de
faire une tentative de suicide je dis
mais à raisonner par ça les conditions
les conditions seront toujours elles
sont déjà ailleurs dans la dans votre
travail vous le soulignez aussi que ce
soit la personne elle-même en état de le
faire intellect psychologue enfin pas
psychologiquement neurologiquement au
niveau cérébral tant qu'elle a sont
discernement
c'est elle qui décide voilà et nous nous
voulons imposer rien à personne mais
nous ne voulons pas non plus qu'on nous
impose un interdit Marcel breton il y a
eu des débats au sein de la convention
sur qu'est-ce qu'on met précisément
derrière cette aide active à mourir
qu'est-ce que derrière ça doit impacter
est-ce que c'est le tanasier est-ce que
c'est le suicide assister est-ce que
c'est le choix est-ce que c'est l'un qui
doit primer sur l'autre on a eu à peu
près les tenants de ce débat pendant
donc 27 jours de travail 9 weekends
pendant quatre mois évidemment on a eu
énormément de sujets abordés ce qui est
particulier avec notre convention c'est
qu'on n'était pas dans une bulle
hermétique c'est forcément on a été
aussi imprégné des débats de d'autres
pays qui par exemple ont pu légiférer il
y a 5 10 15 20 ans qui aujourd'hui du
coup se pose de nouvelles questions se
lier à la question des de l'âge des
mineurs la des souffrances
psychiatriques des souffrances
psychiques voire existentielles tous ces
sujets là en fait on a on a dû entre
guillemets on a voulu aussi prendre et
tout débattre ça veut pas dire qu'on a
tranché sur tout et typiquement sur ces
questions là les plus les plus complexes
les plus difficiles et on a entendu
beaucoup de professionnels médical on a
quand même mené plus d'une soixantaine
d'auditions
tout ça pour aboutir donc à peu près 75%
qui votent pour l'aide active à mourir
mais là dedans on a un nuancier de 19
modèles donc on a 19 visions différentes
d'une vision qui est presque une
extension de la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès donc le cadre
existant à des modèles qui sont sur ce
qu'on a appelé une ouverture un accès
universel à l'aide activé mourir qui
soit uniquement basé
sur la question de la volonté du
discernement et non pas sur des critères
des sur médicale a priori et là dedans
on a tout cette éventail de modèles le
ce les modèles qui sont les plus mis en
avant sont restes dans la question de la
fin de vie dans le milieu médical
les questions plus existentielles
restent un débat et des positionnements
minoritaires mais dans la question
majoritaire de conditions médicales on a
abordé évidemment l'incurabilité de la
maladie les souffrances réfractaires
physiques psychiques psychiatrique et
psychique l'âge etc une question à
chacun pour conclure il nous reste
malheureusement peu de temps Emmanuel
Macron a renvoyé le débat une loi qui
sera présentée d'ici la fin de l'été
qu'attendez-vous de cette loi j'attends
de la sagesse de notre président de la
République on puisse avoir un modèle à
la française qui me semble très
intéressant plutôt que de plaquer parce
qu'il y a un aspect culturel dans la fin
de vie dans la mort par exemple un
modèle beige qui n'est pas du tout notre
modèle à la française c'est le
renforcement des soins palliatifs
ce que vous attendez qu'est-ce que vous
attendez vous n’y vient moi aussi le
renforcement des soins palliatifs mais
l'ouverture d'une possibilité de choisir
une aide active à mourir pour les
personnes qui le souhaiteraient et je
prétends haut et fort qu'il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité entre les soins
palliatifs et une aide active à mourir
et que c'est un acte qui est
effectivement met en jeu énormément de
choses et certainement très pénible pour
les médecins mais que beaucoup de
médecins sont quand même prêts à faire
voilà Marcel breton la conclusion est-ce
que vous regrettez qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
vous ne se soit pas engagé sur tel ou
tel de vos propositions est-ce que vous
espérez être associé à la rédaction de
la loi alors plusieurs choses
que les annonces qui ont été faites
étaient ce qu'on pouvait attendre je
n'aurais pas pu attendre à ce qu'ils
nous disent je reprends exactement
toutes les propositions on sait le
travail enfin les les manquements liés à
la précédente convention sur le climat
où on a un sentiment de trahison par
rapport aux promesses etc là on nous a
annoncé qu'il va y avoir un travail de
l'exécutif et du législatif d'ici l'été
un projet de loi qui va commencer à être
construit donc on est sur un calendrier
cours moi je trouve ça plutôt positif ça
reste à chaud ça reste dans nos têtes
etc on a terminé l'acte 1 il l'a dit on
se lance sur l'acte 2 tout ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'on soit impliqué dans
dans ce travail et qu'on est les deux
piliers de nos travaux qui sont les
recommandations de la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie et on suivra
bien sûr tout ça on en parlera avec vous
puisque le projet de loi effectivement
ne devrait pas tarder à être présenté
vous restez avec nous on va regarder ce
qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux tout de suite
[Musique]
et Alex on reparle informe des retraites
et oui retraite le dialogue est-il pour
demain c'est la question que pose le
journal Le Télégramme à la veille de la
rencontre entre la première ministre
Elisabeth borne et l'Inter syndicale à
quoi va servir cette rencontre et bien à
pas grand chose si ce n'est à réaffirmer
les positions des deux camps
l'intersyndical va défendre le retrait
plus et simple de la réforme même si la
CFDT souhaite une mise en pause une
suspension du texte côté gouvernement et
bien l'objectif c'est d'ouvrir le jeu au
delà du report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite et plutôt d'évoquer d'autres
sujets comme la retraite progressive ou
la reconversion en fin de carrière une
autre question à la Une de La Dépêche du
Midi quel avenir pour la nups après la
victoire d'une dissidente socialiste
dans l'élection législative partielle en
arrière je contre la députée sortante
insoumise soutenue par la nupes cette
défaite mais à mal à la stratégie
clivant de Jean-Luc Mélenchon notamment
pendant le débat sur la réforme des
retraites il avait par exemple
vré pour que le report à 64 ans ne soit
pas discuté à l'Assemblée nationale
contre la vie des syndicats cela met
également en lumière les divisions du
Parti socialiste avec d'un côté elle est
partisans de la nupes qui sont emmenés
par le premier secrétaire du Parti
Olivier Faure et de l'autre les
opposants à cette alliance dominée par
la France insoumise des opposants qui
sont tellement emmenés par Carole Delga
la présidente de la région Occitanie
merci merci beaucoup Véronique le chef
des Nouettes d'avoir été avec nous merci
ma salle breton merci Anne Vivian pour
ce débat sur la fin de vie évidemment on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler on voit
votre livre Véronique Lefebvre de Noël
qui s'affiche merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis
[Musique]